[Musique]
je m'appelle dimitri pour sackhoff je
suis un ancien soliste du ballet de
moscou n'y a pas eu froid fait j'ai
quitté ce théâtre et chercher une
nouvelle place désormais je travaille au
ballet du kremlin
bonne chance merci ja je m'appelle
alexandra timofeyeva je suis danseuse
étoile du ballet du kremlin
imaginez ce que c'est de travailler dans
un endroit pareil
[Musique]
c'est ma 17e saison dans ce théâtre
je suis venu travailler ici à 16 ans et
vous savez je me suis jamais dit oh mon
dieu je travaille au kremlin je n'ai
jamais ce sentiment c'est seulement plus
tard petit à petit quand j'ai compris
des choses quand je me suis habitué que
j'ai commencé à regarder autour de moi
et me rendre compte et minimath
imaginez ce que c'est de travailler dans
un endroit pareil le kremlin de moscou
c'est le coeur de la russie
aujourd'hui c'est ma première journée
dans ce théâtre
j'espère que tout ira bien j'allais au
kremlin à la réunion de la troupe du
ballet c'est mon nouveau lieu de travail
je me suis perdu dans les couloirs du
palais des concerts du kremlin je me
suis perdue en chemin les tutus ça doit
être plus haut je me souviens plus
laitages un autre peut-être assister
correct
entrez ici aller heureusement que
j'étais à l'heure en entrant dans la
salle
je me suis senti quand même un peu mal à
l'aise comme n'importe quel nouveau
[Applaudissements]
bonjour charlie je suis content de vous
voir
je ne savais pas quel rôle ombre
confierait et j'avais très envie qu'on
me donne de bons rôles des rôles
intéressants
je comprenais bien sûr que la troupe
était de haut niveau et que ce ne serait
pas facile ici le répertoire est plutôt
classique
c'est ce que j'aime et c'est ce que je
veux faire le théâtre ballet moscou je
travaille avant opté principalement pour
la chorégraphie moderne
c'est pourquoi je les quitte et frau
sackhoff dimitri dimitri vient me voir
dis moi bien boire
radiomee je voudrais te dire deux mots
je n'étais pas le seul nouveau ce jour
là mais le directeur artistique m'a
appelé dans son bureau ce qui m'a
beaucoup surpris parce que je voulais te
dire tu remplaces s'il te plaît assieds
toi parce que je sais tu es un danseur
classique
nous allons travailler avec toi dans
cette direction nous avons un souci en
ce moment avec le ballet rousse l'année
ludmila car l'artiste qui jouait par la
fnac it est en effet c'est un rôle
important
il a du caractère mais pour ce rôle il
faut connaître les classiques les
pirouettes toutes les danses voudrait
donc que tu es une attitude sérieuse
face à ce rôle parce que toi l'essentiel
maintenant est de commencer à apprendre
tout le répertoire
il faut que tu commences à prendre le
rôle de phare l'afld dès aujourd'hui
d'accord oui merci tu as peut-être des
comment bien sûr c'est site inattendu
c'est une grosse responsabilité
merci ça ne te fait pas trop peur ça va
non non c'est tout simplement inattendue
de recevoir une telle promotion tout de
suite si on embauche on embauche on
compte sur toi d'accord nous allons
travailler avec toi et à la brosse est
d'accord merci beaucoup je vais tout
faire pour ne pas vous décevoir
allez voilà c'était pour ça merci
alors tout va très bien
oui c'est bien vous savez quand
j'embauche quelqu'un je sais déjà ce
qu'il va danser il suffit de voir ses
capacités
c'est comme ajouter une pièce à une
mosaïque il y a quelques problèmes car
il n'est pas très grand
il faut lui trouver une fille de petite
taille si on lui en trouve une
il pourra danser dans casse noisette des
rôles comme ça mais les danseuses
principal de notre théâtre sont assez
grandes
ben ali chassé dessus à vrai dire je ne
me souviens pas du premier jour de
dimitri s'il ya une personne flamboyante
dans un ensemble on la voit tout de
suite
quant à lui je me rappelle qu'il était
dans son coin silencieux comme s'il ne
tenait pas à s'intégrer à la troupe
[Musique]
je ne me sentais pas encore à l'aise
dans ma nouvelle équipe tout le monde
s'occuper de leurs affaires et personne
ne me prête attention
l'indifférence de mes nouveaux collègues
ne me touchez pas vraiment je pensais
rôle de phare l'afld
c'était la première répétition et je le
connaissais pas du tout j'étais inquiet
j'avais trouvé une vidéo pour la prendre
dimitri tu as déjà regarder quelque
chose oui un peu on va voir maintenant
alors le rondo de faire la faute à papa
échappés par le dos en face le double il
ya me papam 5 6 7 et 1 2 pirouette je ne
savais pas à quoi m'attendre avec
dimitri d'autant plus qu'il n'avait vu
aucun spectacle et ne savais pas en quoi
consistait le rôle de phare l'afld
moscou reuters attention ne
correspondait pas du tout à l'image de
phares l'afld
un jeune homme détendu qui fait les cent
coups amateurs de bonne chère et de 20
le rôle de phare l'a fait très compliqué
un autre danseur s'y préparent également
mais ben avec vadim clemens qui avec un
autre enseignant c'était une précaution
d'andrei petrov parce que je venais
d'arriver il ne me connaissait pas assez
tu arrives tu vois je fais tout ce que
tu veux tu prends un verre et tu bois tu
t'approches quelle belle cerise la
première répétition c'est un coup
d'essai je testais les capacités de
dimitri son caractère et dimitri
m'observait aussi s'habituer à moi on
peut le comprendre on lui en demande
énormément et il est un peu perdue vers
les filles vers les filles on attend
juste mais sur un sofa
venait vers moi venez et vous aussi je
vous en prie faites moi plaisir
dimitri a été choisi parce qu'ils
avaient déjà un parcours assez riche
lauréat de nombreux concours il devait
avoir un bon talent artistique
nous avons pris un risque je voudrais
que vous me qualifiez puisqu elles se
sont empressés de venir yam papa papa
mme hétu dégringole et tu te relèves
le tempo est très rapide le personnage
est haut en couleurs c'était difficile à
transmettre
il restait peu de temps et j'avais peur
de ne pas y arriver
un porc à la broche rôti que la trappe
par les deux pieds et tu fais comme si
tu l'observer au quel joli port tu le
portes au dessus de toi un beau petit
port
tu le fais tourner et boum il est par
terre je fais ça et en même temps je n'y
pense pas je pense à la suite
oui oui je pense c'est ça il faut que je
me retienne voilà pourquoi nous répétons
plusieurs fois maintenant merci merci
beaucoup
une vraie bonne journée après la
première répétition je n'étais pas sûr
que dimitri arriverait je connaissais
mal dimitri je ne comprenais pas ses
capacités ses facultés
tout dépend des lui
voilà je travaille au ballet du kremlin
aujourd'hui c'est mon premier spectacle
ma première je danse par l'afld dans le
ballet rousse l'année ludmila j'espère
que tout ira bien
peu de temps les spectacles en première
partie de la journée c'est bien mais pas
à midi à 2 heures ça va encore mais un
spectacle à midi c'est pas trop luxueux
ici ah oui c'est luxueux
vous savez après la rénovation quand
nous sommes entrés ici pour la première
fois j'avais mal aux yeux à cause de
tout cet or c'est inhabituel
et puis on s'est habitué c'est très
confortable ici
le plancher est chauffée un canapé un
sofa
j'adore parfois quand nous avons une
répétition le matin un spectacle le soir
[Applaudissements]
les adhésifs ici c'est comme une sorte
de sculpture peinture
il faut faire en sorte qu'un visage
maigre deviennent gros autant que
possible il sera gros il est censé être
gros parce que c est un amateur de bonne
chère et de boissons je n'ai d'un c'est
le ballet russe l'âme et ludmilla qu
deux fois c'était avant la dernière
saison il m'est arrivé de danser à la
première et j'avais après le spectacle
en quatre jours quand andré petrov m'a
dit qu'il fallait le faire
j'ai paniqué je lui ai dit que je ne
parviendrai pas aussi rapidement et il
m'a répondu si tu le feras je me
rappelle que le premier spectacle mado
net en adrénaline
c'était comme l'explosion d'une bombe on
m'a littéralement poussé sur scène
oui et aujourd'hui honnêtement ce n'est
pas seulement l'ouverture de la saison
je peux dire que pour moi aussi c'est
une première car deux ans ont passé
depuis que je les danses et pour la
première fois que j'ai appris à lattes
cette fois je me suis préparé beaucoup
plus longtemps et avec beaucoup plus de
sérieux
sacha pourquoi tu sautes mon souffle
je travaille mon souffle son génie c'est
plus difficile de danser avec les bottes
c'est une sensation tout à fait
différente
le point d'appui est différent avec les
sauces ça va mais atterrir c'est déjà
plus compliqué le pied peut bouger il
faut donc faire attention si l'on est
soudainement trop détendu on peut se
blesser
dieu m'en garde des killers s'il vous
plaît vous savez 16h40 vous avez encore
le temps
toi oui moi non je dois encore monter
fait plus vite si tu peux je couds les
talons ce n'est pas la soliste et de
coudre ses pointes
mais si comment on peut le confier à
quelqu'un d'autre
les costumes oui ce sont les costumières
qui nous les cous recousent mais les
pointes ses personnels regard si en face
il faut aussi non il faut pas ça va
mercier d'accord bonnes chansons
[Musique]
bon courage et merci
très bien fixer la perruque oui oui hier
oui il y aura pas de problème
non ça va ces clous et j'ai fait ce que
j'ai pu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ennuyée j'ai le trac avant chaque
spectacle
mais quand on prépare la première c'est
un sentiment particulier une sorte de
tremblements en plus j'avais un nouveau
partenaire dimitrije j'étais aussi
inquiète pour lui
je ne savais pas comment elle allait
s'en sortir
[Musique]
non
je n'avais encore jamais eu la chance de
danser sur une scène aussi grande que
celle du palais du kremlin
c'était très dur physiquement parce
qu'il faut parcourir de grandes
distances
c'est surtout difficile de garder son
souffle
[Musique]
à quoi je pense qu'on trouve nulle part
une scène pareille il faut lui parler
lui dire très bonne
nous t'aimons nous travaillons ici nous
serons des amis
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'était facile pour moi de travailler
avec sacha timofei bas parce que nous
avions tout vérifié pendant la
répétition
c'est une danseuse expérimentée et
talentueuse
le seul problème était mon costume qui
était très lourd
je transpirais beaucoup je dégoulinait
c'était donc compliqué il fallait tout
le temps mais suit y est il fallait me
tamponné tout le temps je suis trempé
je pourrais vous montrer après trempé de
la tête aux pieds
sa guise à 6 tours repose toi
[Musique]
je veux dire aujourd'hui c'est plus
facile qu'hier je ne sais pas comment va
être le deuxième acte mais là ça va
première rentrée
[Musique]
hier c'était la première entrée en scène
de la saison oui oui hier ne sont entrés
sur scène après les vacances pour la
répétition et pour régler les lumières
mais on n'était pas vraiment à l'aise
aujourd'hui ça va déjà mieux
j'ai eu des soucis avec ma perruque
pendant ce spectacle j'ai essayé
plusieurs fois de la rangée j'espère que
ça ne s'est pas vue et danser sur les
talons c'est vraiment pas facile
[Musique]
j'ai confondu les coulisses j'ai pris un
peu de retard après chevallier poignardé
partie 3
d'où le deuxième acte jeu ne sort
pratiquement pas de scène
allez la première monte et attire pas
trop fort
il faut la mettre un peu ici ab c'est
maintenant au début de l'acte 2 j'arrive
dans le royaume de cherno more et là on
me soulève sur un lit à une hauteur de
plus de 2 m lorsque le rideau est fermé
la scène est plongée dans le noir
tout est noir et on me soulève à ce
moment précis pour moi c'est l'un des
pires moments du spectacle parce que
j'ai peur du vide
il va falloir que tu t'attaches tu as
des sangles non il ya toujours une main
au cas où oui je sais c'est château à ça
au moins je vérifie chaque fois ci tout
est en place pour que rien ne se rompe
pour que je ne tombe pas ça y est on
commence oui
dans le noir le silence le rideau est
déjà fermé les lumières sont éteintes
cette fois alors comme soulever le lui a
bougé et je poussais un grand cri
j'espère que personne ne l'a entendu
dans la salle je crois que c'était assez
fort
oh
ici on te mettais des boules ici je
regardais de plus les collèges tuant
ventre si grands hommes et tué six
maigres des jus à ce n'est pas assez
mais non j'ai dit qu'on pourrait mettre
des petites boules derrière les gens
vous l'y a fait tout ce qu'elle pouvait
je vais dire des boules des boules nong
à l'ena comment danser avec monf le bien
les joues alors voila sinon c'est quoi
au moins aux moments les plus importants
oui oui bien sinon c'était très bien que
bien dans la musique avec souplesse avec
précision hier j'ai regardé la
répétition même quand tu manges et
c'était avec la musique tu mords des
taux avec précision avec la logique du
bon travail
merci j'aime ça écoute max tu peux me le
refaire mais encore une fois comme tu
l'as fait hier j'en veux plus à
m'étrangler
[Musique]
les spectateurs dans la salle n'ont
aucune idée de ce qui se passe derrière
le rideau en fait nous avons beaucoup de
décors dans le spectacle et nous nous
cachons derrière parfois j'avais le
temps de faire mes petits trucs derrière
alors que les spectateurs sont
pratiquement là voilà les spectateurs
sont derrière le rideau moi je suis là
et ça me dérange pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
déjà j'avais peur déporté avec far
l'afld parce que en fait j'ai peur des
portes et tout court
en plus je ne le connais pas vraiment je
veux dire en tant que professionnel je
n'ai jamais travaillé avec lui sur scène
et c'est toujours une cause de stress
j'ai touché par hasard ma moustache et
elle s'est décollée j'ai donc dû jouer
la moitié de la scène tournée de côté
après pendant la pause j'ai couru vers
la maquilleuse
comme on n'avait pas le temps de mon
colis de nouvelles elle m'a simplement
décidé de moustache
[Musique]
allez bon courage
e
[Musique]
il
moralement c'était très difficile parce
que c'était mon premier spectacle de la
saison
mon premier spectacle dans une nouvelle
troupe le rôle n'était pas facile mais
j'ai réussi de ce point de vue j'ai été
fier de moi
allez allez allez vas-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va oui je n'ai pas eu le temps c'est
pas grave je me suis levé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
dimitri sur un très beau chat je pense
c'est dimitri n'est ce pas oui il
comprend oui d'abord il est très
intelligent non l'artiste sérieux oui je
voudrais qu'ils aillent plus haut oui
plus haut au moins d'une dizaine de
centimètres
j'ai l'impression que sacha grandi et
les grands maintenant elle se trouvait
on voit déjà à quel point l expert c'est
pour ça que j'ai l'impression que sacha
a grandi sur le plus grande avec méchant
maintenant elle est très bien là allez-y
allez-y
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup bon travail merci j'étais
fatigué moralement et physiquement mais
qu andry petrov s'est approché et m'a
fait des compliments
j'étais très content je voulais bien sûr
monde et le costume parce que je ne
supportais plus il faisait beaucoup trop
chaud
félicitations bravo merci voilà je sais
que c'est difficile de sauter dans ce
costume et ont joué comme ça à peu près
et je voudrais tu t'envoles plus haut
que ça te grandissent d'accord il faut
te faire grandir de 10 centimètres ça ne
suffit pas toujours d'accord
parfois ça c'est bien ok ça te soulèvera
d'accord d'accord parce que pour
d'autres rôles la taille c'est important
lorsque tout a pris fin je me suis
sentie apaisé parce que c'était fini
mais parce que j'avais réussi
j'avais réussi à faire un bon spectacle
à préparer un nouveau danseur je n'avais
pas honte de notre travail
tout le monde l'a félicité l'équipe l'a
apprécié je pense qu'on l'a acceptée
dans la famille c'est important
approchez approchez n'ayez pas peur
très bien il a été très bien comme s'ils
avaient dansé toute sa vie avec moi en
tout cas
il avait la main ferme linteau cio avec
moi tu as perdu quelque chose ma
moustache
booth
voilà encore une un bon c'est incroyable
vous me surprenez c'est comme trouver
une aiguille dans une botte de foin
à mon avis la saison a très bien
commencé
le spectacle a été une belle réussite
certes il ya encore des petits trucs des
petits moments on aurait pu faire mieux
quelques-uns c'est normal c'était de bon
niveau mais pas comme on l'aurait voulu
mais nous sommes des humains n'est ce
pas pas des machines
[Musique]